This is Chris.
This is a real passenger Chris is driving.
Chris asked these lyft passengers
to share intimate
stories from their lives.
- What's the worst way that
you've been broken-up with?
Was it your heart that was broken?
- Well, yea.
- Bad breakups, man.
- Yea so that's the story,
that's the breakup story.
Ride/Share: Your best breakup stories
- My breakup story is
I was dating this guy, no I'm actually
kinda embarrassed to tell it.
- Tell it, tell us the whole thing.
- So I was dating this guy
We were together for three years.
And we broke up for one day, for one day
because--
- [Chris] Who broke up
with who?
- [Girl] No, no, no he thought
I was hooking up with someone else,
but it wasn't true, and so
we broke up that night,
the next morning he texts me,
'Let's get back together.'
And I was like, 'Ok'.
Nine months later, that
one night we broke up,
he #*&@ some other girl (claps) and
realized he was a father
now, nine months later.
(laughs/surprises)
- No way!
- Oh my God!
(screams)
- Ok so then anyway, nine months later
this girl calls him up
cause she had a boyfriend,
and thought it was her boyfriend's
but when she had the baby,
he took a paternaty test, it wasn't his,
so then she calls up my
boyfriend and was like,
'By the way, you have a kid.'
So then he tells me, and I'm like,
'Whoa, that's way too crazy
'we have to be done.'
And then we were done.
- I actually moved to Los Angeles
to get away from this guy.
- Where are you from originally?
- From Philadelphia.
- #&$6 I didn't even know this.
(laughs)
- You didn't know I was from Philly?
Or you didn't know the story.
- I of course know
you're from @#&^ Philly.
- I was about to say, 'I've
known you for five years!'
- I didn't know you were fleeing an ex.
- It was bad, he destroyed my things,
he destroyed my artwork,
he broke my computer.
The entire time that
him and I were together,
he was cheating on me,
and this one girl he had sex with
was a white chick from ^$^%& North Philly
with cornrows (chuckles)
I forget her name... Angel.
(laughs)
There was one thing he
told me never to touch.
And I respected this, he is, (laughs)
such a $#&& idiot.
He had the entire Dune
collection, the books.
And then my roommate, Tod goes,
'You know what would make
you feel better right now?
'If we burned all of those @&*@
Dune books in the backyard.'
So then I called my other guy friends,
so at this point we're in my backyard
I had this like big fire pit.
I was just sittin' there
with my feet kicked up
rippin' books apart throwing
them in the &@# fire,
and then the best part and we're here,
this is the ender, ready?
So I go 'I hope that mother
&%% can smell his books
'burning from here,' and then we hear,
'What?' and then we all look over.
He $%&# walked through the
side gate into the backyard,
and was like 'That's my *#$ shit.
He actually tried to charge at me,
and then all my boys got in front of me
and were like, 'Try it mother @&#&'
- Oh my gosh.
- Yea it was awesome.
And I was like I never
wanna &%#@& see you again.
- Dude, he's lucky they didn't just
beat the &%#@ out of him
just for the hell of it.
- Well you know, I wanted them to,
but we're better than that.
- But it's Philly, city of peace and love.
- (laughs) City of brotherly love.
- I was with someone for four years,
the first year was great,
let me just say that.
- Why is it always guys cheating?
- Hey, don't say that.
(expletives)
- Let me say there are plenty
of amazing guys right here.
- So we've been dating for four years,
and I finally had enough one day,
and I was like, 'Listen, I
think we should break up'
I get home a few hours later,
and I go upstairs to my
room to change into my pjs,
and there's someone in my bed.
- Nooo.
- And I was like, 'Hey,
maybe we shouldn't break up'
I was being a huge wussy
about the whole thing.
I was like, 'I love you',
and I pull over the
covers, and it's a girl.
- There's a girl in your bed?
- It get worse, she
was wearing my pajamas,
(screams of surprise)
my T-shirt, in my bed.
- Would you guys wear the same size pjs?
- Mmmhm it was tightest on her.
But before I could get outside
my ex-boyfriend was so psycho
he kept shutting the garage on me
so I couldn't leave the house.
- That's why you never give
a boyfriend the clicker.
- That's what I'm sayin',
but they gave us two, their mistake.
(laughs)
So I'm trying to get out
and he won't let me out
and I'm like in my car
and he puts the garage down on my car
so now my car is #$@% up
I'm $$#%$# up, I'm crying,
I just leave my keys in the ignition
and I run and call my
cousin to come pick me up.
- But now we're living the life,
and we couldn't be happier.
- So thank you!
- We're going to Argentina!
- Gracias mucho.
- Gracias!
- So you guys met at work?
- I was in a very long
relationship, seven years.
- Wow!
- And I was engaged to be married.
- It started out like a friendship because
your girlfriend was never around,
my boyfriend was never around.
So we started hanging out.
- I just couldn't believe how
there could be anyone in the world
that was exactly like me.
Just the fact that there's
someone like her out there,
like I shouldn't be with the person
I'm in right now so I broke up.
Two days later she broke
up with her boyfriend,
and by the end of the week,
we were together, a year
later we were married,
and so far it's been seven years total.
Special Thanks to Lyft